you still watch some of your like high
school highlights is that true yeah I
watch them I hate watching them because
I get like depressed like the freedom of
movement before injuries and things like
that kind of aren't the same at this
point in my career I've been rehabbing
while I've been playing so when you talk
about like freedom of movement you're
saying it kind of just reminds you now
of like I used to be moving like this I
always think like okay if I didn't get
injured like how good would I be right
now I'm not at 100 I haven't been for a
while but I'm trying to get there I've
gotten better in certain areas of the
game but definitely some things would
have been affected by the injuries it's
good looking back I just can't watch
them too long